بدايه متعثره للروندي سانتس الطامح في
هزيمه ترامب وقياده الحزب الجمهوري في
سباق الرئاسه الامريكيه العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
ديسانتس اختار تويتر
فانهار الموقع وتعثر الاتصال
وانقطاع متواصل في الاتصال برره ايلون
ماسك صاحب الموقع بالضغط الهائل على
الشبكه وكثره المعجبين ترامب ساخره من ذلك
وعلق على منصته
مفتاحيه الاحمر اكبر وافضل واقوى ويعمل
جيدا مفتاحك لا يعمل بايدن انتهز الفرصه
ايضا نشر رابطا لحملته وكتب هذا الموقع
يعمل
لقد صمدنا عندما تم تهديد الحريه اطهرنا
اننا نستطيع ويجب اعاده احياء امريكا نحن
بحاجه الى الشجاعه للقياده والقوه للفوز
انا راندي سانتوس اعلن ترشحي الانتخابات
الرئاسه لقياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى
ورغم البدايه المتعثره تقنيا
الا انه تمكن من جمع مليون دولار في ساعه
واحده لدعم حملته الانتخابيه ما يعني انه
لن يكون منافسا سهلا لا للترامب ولا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات